hello everybody my name is Merle I am a
tasty creator and today I'm going to
show you a video of my favorite vegan
holiday dish sustainability is really
important to me and one of the easiest
ways to be sustainable is with your diet
I'm vegan but I still like really good
food so I decided to take my favorite
dessert and make it vegan this way I get
to enjoy the food I've always loved and
I can introduce people who aren't vegan
to really good vegan cooking I also
don't want to be that kind of vegan
that's like shoving my veganism down
your throat so I figured a really easy
way to introduce people to vegan baking
is by making dishes they already loved
this vegan cinnamon roll recipe came
about because I was doing a seven day
vegan week initiative and this just
happened to be my favorite recipe that
came out of those seven days one thing
that I love about this recipe is that
it's really really easy to substitute
because basically you're just
substituting milk with a plant-based
milk and butter with vegan butter -
totally easy and fairly accessible
ingredients that most people have listen
I keep baking like I keep baking I'm
horrible at its science it's hard it's
for me the most intimidating part is the
yeast factor yeast can die and I'm vegan
I don't like things dying so one thing
that I recommend is that when you put
your yeast and just let it sit for a
minute don't try to stir it if that
mistake it will be a youth genocide and
nobody needs that on the holidays the
recipe is pretty straightforward the
hardest part is really just trying to
work the dough out into a nice soft but
not sticky workable though that you can
roll out and then you can put as much
cinnamon and sugar as you want I chose
these vegan cinnamon rolls because this
is the first vegan recipe that I made
where I actually could not tell the
difference between this version and then
the original version I remember making
these cinnamon rolls and then handing
them out to people in my office and
nobody could tell that they were vegan
this is a dish that you can bring to a
potluck you can have it
higher tree oven yourself which I have
done on multiple occasions this recipe
is so easy that you can kind of
customize it however you want so one
thing I can guarantee you is that you're
gonna love it
your friends and family and your
probably made way to make my favorite
part of making this recipe is because
you might have a little bit of extra
dough left over and then you can make
use like really yummy vegan crust
cookies with some brown sugar and some
of that vegan butter it's really hard to
mess this recipe up I'll be honest with
you again I'm not a professional Baker
baking has never really been my forte
but this is my favorite dessert make
sure at one point to peek inside the
oven because these things rise in a
really beautiful gray they get nice and
crispy and golden brown
super super satisfying not to mention
the smell is going to have you pull
eyeing through your day and the icing is
really really easy to make - all you
need is powdered sugar any sort of
plant-based milk and you can use oat
milk almond milk soy milk whatever
tickles your fancy the icing you can
play with the portions of the powdered
sugar and the liquid because depends if
you want a more liquidy icing or if you
want to thicker icing one thing that's
really important to me in vegan baking
is that I'm not having less than
versions of all the things I've always
known and loved I still deserve to be
indulgent in the holidays and I want a
recipe that's gonna make me reminiscent
of my childhood and just because it's
vegan doesn't mean it can't be
incredibly delicious the only difference
between these vegan salmon rolls and the
cinnamon rolls I always used to eat as a
kid is that I don't feel terrible after
I eat them so that just means I get to
eat more fun which to me is a win-win
[Music]
thank you so much for watching everyone
I hope you love this recipe as much as I
do
my goal is a tasty creator is to offer
you fantastic recipes that are going to
be really delicious and just a little
healthier that you can love whether
you're vegan or not happy holidays
everybody
[Music]